avec tous les appareils ménagers dans
tel dispose aujourd'hui les femmes n'ont
vraiment pas de quoi se plaindre
qu'est-ce qu'être femme
être femme c'est ce que je suis vous
avez toute une liste des questions comme
ça
parce que je trouve pas que ça soit
spécialement intelligent comme
[Musique]
il faut croire au bon Dieu
et puis
[Musique]
c'est une comment dirais-je une source
de reproduction des caprices déjà c'est
c'est les énervements à une période on
sait plus si elle est de bonne humeur de
mauvaise humeur le matin moi je me lève
avec un sourire ma femme me laisse
deux fois par semaine et des fois elle a
pas du tout le bonheur des femmes
dépendent des hommes c'est très très
simple mais ça représente beaucoup de
choses une femme
ça représente c'est c'est le bonheur
ça peut être le mal aussi je trouve
c'est agressif une femme un homme
elle représente la moitié de la
population du globe elles en ont mis au
monde la totalité ce qui leur vaut
depuis l'aube des temps la
reconnaissance des hommes
Molière était catégorique du côté de la
barbe et la toute puissance
Voltaire disait avoir vu des femmes
guerrières des Femmes savantes mais
jamais d'avant triste la femme est
donnée à l'homme pour qu'elle fasse des
enfants
quand l'homme s'interrogeait sur
l'humanité il disait toujours l'homme le
temps est peut-être venu de dire aussi
la femme la femme
n'a pas tous les avantages qu'un homme a
et encore
l'agence au travail par exemple souvent
une journée chargée parce que non
seulement elle travaille à l'extérieur
mais elle travaille chez elle également
alors que l'homme lorsqu'il arrive chez
lui en principe non la maison il se met
les pieds sous la table
avec tous les appareils ménagers dont
elle dispose aujourd'hui des femmes
n'ont vraiment pas de quoi se plaindre
la condition féminine ça existe pour
vous oui ça existe mais pas plus que la
condition des employés ou que la
condition des travailleurs ou que la
condition n'est pas trop c'est un
problème comme un autre c'est pas un
problème de sexe Auguste affirmait
physique la femme est incapable de tout
gouvernement les conditions féminines
existent
disons que
il y a des femmes actuellement qui se
battent
il y a des femmes qui prennent la parole
et je pense que même en silence il y a
des femmes qui font avancer la condition
féminine même celles qui ne sont pas
connues à l'heure actuelle mais je pense
qu'on est pas arrivé encore à une
égalité non pour moi être une femme
c'est d'abord
être obligé de
me plier à des exigences extérieures
[Musique]
et puis
être la victime des apparences selon un
journaliste de 1920 la nature a fait les
femmes pour tout porter les enfants les
coûts et les peines des hommes c'est
très très bien dans ma peau justement je
préfère être femme à notre époque car on
peut avoir ses propres décisions vivre
comme on dit de ses propres ailes faire
ce que l'on veut on travaille on a notre
mot à dire mais je sais pas du tout MLF
je me sens très bien dans ma peau je
peux pas l'impression que je me
sentirais bien dans la peau d'un homme
je suis bien dans ma peau je suis très
bien je suis très contente d'être une
femme oui elle y a du jour où je me sens
comme beaucoup de femmes exploités si on
peut dire ça avec beaucoup trop de
choses à faire à la maison puis d'autres
où je me sens très bien comme ça très
contente d'être une femme surtout en
1975 pourquoi 1975 il y a des tas de
possibilités que je n'aurais pas eu il y
a un siècle par exemple ou deux
[Musique]